Padma no you look always say Kylie
Minogue by the way Graham Norton I dunno
why I say Pedigo no I'll just say Carly
but now it comes I like it Halima no
it's out yeah yeah if I knew I was ever
gonna be famous I wouldn't have chosen
that lots of people then they're
children Kylie lots and lots of it was a
period where it was Carly Charlene I
believe cleanliness of eating Charlene
second name any Kylie's named after
Kylie well good news Ducati me no fans
I've got to say all over the world but
basically the m25 area a big Hyde Park
extravaganza next month 21st of June
longest day of the year so what can
people expect
well I can kind of sunset but I I can
barely believe that that I say this my
support acts are Christ's urns
not busy I hope she at one point chic
featuring Nile Rodgers Wow Wow
mica and years and years and some others
and I'd love to be the some others
wouldn't you right now body's going
through the bill
[Applause]
I guess for some others throw another
bike by the way that picture of Grace
Jones there is that where you got the
idea
is it really where you go do this around
that time of the fever album she was one
of our inspirations my creative picture
of you with yes and also to see the
album cover which is kind of yes that is
Grace Jones Grace Jones inspired you
yeah
I also wants to ask you that can't get
you out of my head choreography is it
true that that was like that for a very
specific reason
well the choreographer Michael Rooney
who's one of the sons of Mickey Rooney
which is already legendary
and the brother of Wayne I believe the
Rooneys are coming to the party he
choreographed it like it was in a box I
think he was in a small hotel room
probably not cheap hotel room was so
small one story I don't know if that's
really true but that's one of the one of
the tales
you
[Music]